at least 90 000 russian troops are
masked along the ukrainian border you
can see the buildup here in these
satellite images that's raising alarms
because in 2014 russia invaded and
annexed territory in the eastern part of
ukraine charlie daggett has covered this
story for years this morning he looks at
how we got to this point
eastern ukraine on full flex military
display and war footing a very russian
style ceremony yesterday packed with u.s
military hardware with president
vladimir zelinsky thanking troops for
protecting the territory and sovereignty
of ukraine the fact is they've been
locked in a battle with russia since
2014. that's when president putin
launched the illegal takeover of crimea
deploying unmarked forces marching in
with local militias but russia's rap
sheet in ukraine was just beginning we
were there on the front lines when
so-called russian separatists backed by
the kremlin invaded eastern ukraine in
what amounted to putin's military
takeover of the region more than 14 000
people have been killed in fighting and
counting the separatists are still there
but loading the gun again at the border
with 90 000 troops artillery and tanks
doesn't necessarily mean he's going to
pull the trigger this time says russia
analyst jeff hahn it's essentially a
signal that russia
sees itself as great power and demands
to be taken seriously and treated as
such particularly by the united states
putin wants to reiterate to the biden
administration what the stakes are
and the stakes couldn't be higher putin
has repeatedly made clear ukraine is
being used as a springboard against
russia this week warning the west of not
crossing any red lines over any idea of
making ukraine part of nato
now that troop build up along the border
is straight out of putin's playbook
whether a genuine threat or a bluff it
gives the russian president exactly what
he's aiming for ahead of this summit
with president biden
leverage
gail
all right charlie jagged reporting from
london we thank you the